what time until we land kylie jenner has
been in a trolling mood lately and
we are here for it i'm having fun the
beauty mogul shared this video on tik
tok using a creepy filter on her sis
kendall jenner and her mom kris jenner's
face
but funny enough the joke started off
with her
[Laughter]
and she ran with it
hello
yeah kendall
what time until we land
33 minutes
we are living for this jokester side of
kylie
during their family trip to italy for
her big sister courtney's wedding
she had no issue roasting kendall who
struggled walking up the steps to the
ceremony in her couture gown
[Music]
these stairs are crazy but that wasn't
the only time she poked fun at her sis
she shared another video on tick tock of
the two at the reception
her caption
me and cucumber girl and if cucumber
girl has you feeling confused well
here's the backstory earlier this month
kindle went viral for her interesting
cucumber cutting technique shown on an
episode of the kardashians do you want
um the chef to make you a snack i'm
making it myself just gotta chop up some
cucumber it's pretty amazing
you go girl
be careful because i cut i nicked myself
the other day i don't know i'm kind of
scared there you go
don't cucumbers have seeds
oh yeah they're definitely
i'm not a good cutter so don't zoom in
on me
i'm not professional whatsoever
the moment made headlines everywhere
kendall reacted to all the talk by
making light of the moment and
sarcastically calling the whole thing
quote tragic and now it seems kylie
wants her sister to embrace the new
cucumber girl nickname the songs on the
radio are okay
but my taste in music is your face
and it takes a song to come around
[Music]
kylie has been pretty active on tick
tock these days and during her time in
italy she blessed us with an inside look
at courtney's lavish wedding ceremony
including this moment of her sis kim
strutting in a diamond studded body
bodysuit at the reception
[Music]
in this video of chris getting down on
the dance floor
[Music]
thanks kylie keep them coming
[Music]